البدايه من كاس العالم ومشاركه المنتخب
السعودي في المونديال الذي قدم اداء مميزا
وقويا في معظم اللقاءات غياب الحظ
والتوفيق والاصابات المؤثره حاله في
النهايه للاسف دون تقدم اكثر في البطوله
الاخضر السعودي والدعاء المنافسه بعد
خساره امام نظيره المكسيكي بهدفين مقابل
هدف لي والدعاء البطوله سويه بعد تاهل
الارجنتين وفولندا لكن الاخضر قدم بشكل
عام طوله تاريخيا ومنتخبا يمكن ان يبنى
عليه للمستقبل استطاع السعاده جماهير
السعوديه وجعلها تؤمن بامكانيات لاعبيها
الذين كانوا على قدر المنافسه
مع نهايه مشاركه السعوديه في النسخه
الثانيه والعشرين من كاس العالم يكون
الاخضر قد غادر من الدور الاول للمره
الخامسه على التوالي بتاريخ مشاركته
لاعبوا المنتخب السعودي سالم الدوسري
يعادل صداره الهدافين العرب بعد السعودي
سامي الجابر والتونسي وهبي الخدري برصيد
ثلاثه اهداف الدوسري سجل في مبارياتين في
دور المجموعات معاديلا رقم مواطنه فؤاد
انور في مونديال
المنتخب السعودي قرر ما فعله في مونديال
روسيا 2018 حيث حقق فوزا واحدا ومنيه
بخسارتين في دور المجموعات السعوديه تلقت
الاهداف للمباراه السادسه عشر على التوالي
في تاريخ مشاركاتها في كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
خساره غير متوقعه للاخضر السعودي تقسيط
خارج بطوله كاس العالم المقامه في قطر بعد
اداء ومستوى قوي قدمه في اولى مباراتين
كما تشاهدون الجمهور السعودي الذي قدم من
مختلف انحاء المملكه
لمؤازره الاخضر السعودي في
هذه البطوله خرج مغادرا من ملعب لوسيل
الذي ملئه عن بكره ابيه الان نلتقي باحد
الجمهور السعودي المشجعين السعوديين
الخارجين من الملعب بشكل عام ما رايكم بعد
خساره المنتخب خروجه من المونديال بمستوى
الاخضر بشكل عام في البطوله والله الحمد
لله على كل حال اولا واخيرا همم المنتخب
ادى في المباراه الاولى اداء جدا مشرف
واداء قوي جدا وهذا الاداء القوي
ساهم في تاثير السلبي على المباريتين
الثاني على بولندا وعلى المكسيك اليوم
شروط ذهني من اللاعبين صراحه اختيارات
المدرب كانت شويه همم ما هي صحيحه التنسيق
اللاعبين في التشكيله منتخب بولندا منتخب
يعني مستوى اقل من عادي ومستوى اقل يعني
متوسط للاقل من عادي لكن المكسيك سرعات
عندهم سرعات لعيبه سريعه فاحنا ضيعناها من
مباراه بولندا من المفروض البلنتي لو
سجلنا كان خلصت امورنا تاهلنا الدوره 16
الفريق الروح راحت وما كان في اداء في
خصوصا في اخر مباراه
تاثرت على اداء المنطقه
شرفنا الصراحه
الامانه شرفنا لكن الاصابات والحظ طبعا
الاصابات لها دور كبير
اييي اصابه سلمان وصابت ياسر الشهراني هذه
يعني
البدله ما قصروا ولكن لهم تاثير تاثير
كبير غيابهم والله ابطالنا نقول لهم شكرا
لكم ما قصرتوا الجمهور ايضا الوفي اللي
حضر من المملكه العربيه السعوديه واشجع
جميع العرب نتيجه الحقيقه امام الارجنتين
هذه البطوله نعتبرها احنا حافز باذن الله
للبطولات القادمه خروج مر للمنتخب السعودي
ومغادره كبيره للجمهور السعودي الذي ملئ
الدوحه خلال الايام الماضيه
باعداد غفيره لمؤازره المنتخب السعودي بعد
تفاؤل كبير اصابهم بعد نتيجه تاريخيه ضد
الارجنتين لكنهم يعزون انخفاض اداء
المنتخب السعودي وخسارتين متتاليتين من
بولندا والمكسيك للاصابات القويه التي
اطاحت بالمنتخب عبد المحسن الحربي
صباح العربيه فهد الشهري فهد يسعد صباحك
خروج مشرف للسعوديه من المونديال بعد اداء
مميز في حديثنا اكثر كيف كانت اجواء
المباراه
جميله بالامس صراحه يعني من حضور الجمهور
توافد الجمهور لشراء التذاكر او بالامس
اول مره موقع الفيفا لبيع التذاكر يعيد
بيع التذاكر لاكثر من مره نظرا لاقبال
الشديد طبعا هي الاليه انه ال- ال-
بيقدر يحصي من همم اشترى التذكره ولم يدخل
اراضي الدوحه فعاد اكثر من مره نظرا
لاقبال على الموقع كان اقبال شديد للامانه
شاهدت انا الالاف خارج الملعب امس انتظر
تذاكر انتظروا موازنه الاخضر الاخضر نعم
غادر ولكنه ترك اسمه تركه العلامه الابرص
العلامه الابرز كانت هنا في الدوحه هو
الجمهور السعودي الجمهور السعودي كان تجده
في كل مكان يحتفل يشجع
ويضع الثقه في لعيبه المنتخب السعودي
ويحتفلون ايضا
الصدر عده همم رسائل عده اهازيج وصلت كل
العالم ايضا جمهور المنتخب السعودي كان
اول جمهور يعمل تيفو في المدرج في تاريخ
كاس العالم بالكامل نعم حتى وان غادر
المنتخب السعودي المجموعات من الدور الاول
ولكن لا زال اسمه
يجون بين الرياضيين هنا لازال اسمه موجود
والمنتخب الذي هزم المنتخب الارجنتيني
المرشح الاول للبطوله
وفهد ان شاء الله كمان يعني في الايام
المقبله نشوف ابتسامتك على الهواء كمان
اكثر واكثر هيك على الصبح ايوه هيك طيب
فهد اليوم
المعلومات اللي همم السعوديين من اكثر
الشعوب العربيه والتواجدا في قطر في
مونديال 20 22 ما هي الخطط السعوديه ما
بعد خروج من المونديال يعني بالنسبه
للتواجد السعودي في قطر
نعم لا زالت تواجد السعودي موجود طبعا
نظرا لقرب المسافه
المشجع السعوديه ليست كلهم سيعود رغم انه
يعني رغم ان انا لا حطنه بعض السعوديين
حضر وهذا شيء يشكر عليه حظر من الحدود او
من المطار الى الملعب وعاد مره اخرى
للمطار
للدوامات اليوم هذا موقف ايجابي موقف
بطولي يحسب للمشجع السعودي ولكن المشجع
السعودي لازال موجود ايضا وسائل الاعلام
لا زال تواجد حتى نهايه كاس العالم ايضا
البيت السعودي البيت السعودي اللي يضم 12
قسم حكومي راح ينشر الثقافه السعوديه وهو
متواجد هنا في الدوحه وعلي اقبال كثيف
ويقع في موقع ممتاز في 12 22 فعاليه يوميه
ثقافيه ومتجر لبيع الادوات السعوديه ومتجر
لبيع القمصان السعوديه وايضا فعاليات
ثقافيه وموسيقيه وعرض مسرح متواجد طول
البطوله
الاسم السعودي موجود الجماهير السعوديه
راح تكون موجوده حتى نهايه همم كاس العالم
العديد من الجماهير السعوديه اذا راح
يستمر اليوم وراح يعني تابعوا المنتخب
المغربي اللي نتمنى ان شاء الله لو
التوفيق ونزفه ان شاء الله
كاول منتخب عربي ان شاء الله يصل لدور 16
ونحتفل جميع ان شاء الله بوصول المنتخب
المغربي هناك جماهير السعوديه كثير بقت في
الدوحه من اجل حضور مباراه المنتخب
المغربي وكندا اليوم في السادس من مساء
الدوحه شكرا جزيلا من الدوحه مراسل صباح
العربيه فهد الشهري